[Musique]
c'est la fête partout au québec dans les
villes les quartiers au maire musique en
mots en décor ce qui représente l'âme du
peuple québécois
après deux ans en fête nationale en
raison de la pandémie les québécois
savoure la liberté mais c'est un bonheur
de pouvoir marcher dans les rues comme
ça librement puis c'est agréable qui
écouter de la musique dans la rue par la
fête elle est là je m'efface a dans sa
vie elle était menée pendant la pandémie
donc ça fait du bien on est content les
gens trouvaient al-sabah s'écoule
à québec comme dans plusieurs autres
villes des artistes ont pris d'assaut
les scènes éphémères être au québec ce
si beau les québécois ensemble c'est
beau je suis tout le monde est gentil et
l'on doit en être fier martèle le
premier ministre en visite à charlemagne
dans sa circonscription
laventure du français en amérique mérite
qu'on la célèbre elle dont l'avenir est
menacé cette nation allocs survécu 411 à
foca continue de sauver sa vie et qu'il
faut protéger de français oui de se
battre contre le multiculturalisme pas
parce qu'on est conclu entre parce que
on est un peuple accueillant mais il ya
un défi d'intégration aux français
à verchères une statue à l'effigié d'un
des plus illustres indépendantiste
l'ancien premier ministre bernard landry
est inauguré
un projet à long terme pour certains
mais à court terme les québécois veulent
fêter les feux d'artifice la mi chou et
neveu de joie la bière qui manque
d'aliments capable de fête pour l'un des
premiers paris 6
jan ici marie josée pas quelques mots
radio canada montréal